also happening today video game  enthusiasts are going to gather this is  sony at southern nevada's oldest bar  it's the pioneer stallone 25 miles south  of las vegas in good springs yeah so  they're celebrating the much-loved video  game called fallout new vegas  [Music]  so the game reimagines a  post-apocalyptic las vegas where you  choose your destiny as a vigilant  messenger  pioneer saloon is hosting the event all  day all ages invited now a little  history here the pioneer saloon opened  in 1913 right before video games became  really popular but if the event is a  success they plan to make it an annual  attraction i love that you've got video  gamers meeting at the pioneer saloon in  good springs it seems to be like the  exact opposite but i love it a lot of  bikers there it's a great bar ghosts you  know a whole bit because the barrels of  booze in the back good notch as well